TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi, I'm Timothy.
RAN NACHMANY: Hi, I'm Ran.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And you're
here with "The Developer
Show" on location at the
Launchpad Accelerator.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Tell me, what is Launchpad?
RAN NACHMANY: In
Launchpad Accelerator,
we work with late stage setups.
And their biggest
challenge is how to grow.
Turns out, in order to
build a successful business,
it's more than just writing
great lines of code.
You need to work on
marketing, on user experience,
on your product strategy,
how you raise funds,
and how you build your company.
We have startups here from
Indonesia, India, Brazil,
and Mexico.
They go back home
and we continue
to work with them for
a period of six months.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's amazing.
RAN NACHMANY: I hope so.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So
we're going to talk
with a few startups today,
and a few of the mentors
about their experience with
the Launchpad Accelerator
and some of the
Google technologies
that they're using.
RAN NACHMANY: Great,
sounds awesome.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Let's get to it.
So I'm now standing here
with Iman and Jordan.
Iman is CEO of a startup that's
at the Launchpad Accelerator,
and Jordan was his mentor.
Iman, tell us a little
bit about your startup.
IMAN: We are Ruangguru.
In English, it means
[? classroom. ?]
So what we're doing is that
we built a learning management
system targeting to K-12
market in Indonesia.
And on the other hand, we also
provide a tool for teachers
and also parents to monitor
how students are performing.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
Now what Google
technologies do you use?
IMAN: One of the things
that we are working on
while we are at
Launchpad is actually
to build a progressive web app.
Because one of things
that we figure out
working in Indonesian market is
that the internet penetration
is very low there.
And the data also
costs very highly.
So that's also one of the
concerns that most of our users
have.
So we're thinking
about the solution
to actually equip our users to
increase speed and conversion,
definitely.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's amazing.
And Jordan's been helping you?
IMAN: Yeah, definitely.
It's been really helpful.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Now,
how's the process been
going, adding in progressive
web apps to this business?
JORDAN: I mean, Ruangguru has
a very straightforward business
in network conditions like
Indonesia, where there's not
always a great
network connection,
where sometimes you
think you're on Wi-Fi,
sometimes you're on 2G,
sometimes you're on 3G.
But really, you're on nothing.
It happens a lot.
And what it allows you
to do is as an app,
you can pull from the
cache on the device
first before having to
go out to the network.
So Ruangguru can
use service workers,
use caching to create a kind
of offline first application
for their web app that enables
students to read content
at home where they might not
have a network connection,
or on the train
where there might not
be any cellular service at all.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's amazing.
Iman, thanks so
much for joining us.
IMAN: Yeah, my pleasure.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Jordan,
you want to stick around
for another one?
JORDAN: For sure.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right.
Anshoo, thank you
for joining us.
ANSHOO: Thank you so much.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Will
you tell us a little bit
about your startup, Magicpin?
ANSHOO: So So the
name Magicpin comes
from pinning a
location on the map,
and we'll show you the
magic around that location.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's great.
ANSHOO: We are a
hyperlocal social network,
where for our users,
we get them to discover
interesting people around
them, interesting merchants
around them.
And from merchants, we let
them tap that local audience,
which is otherwise very hard
for them to reach out to.
So they can increase
new customers
for themselves, increase
revenue when they are in trust,
and then also just generally
connect with the users who
live in that locality.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Very cool.
And you've been
working with Jordan
on creating a
progressive web app.
ANSHOO: And the sessions
have been great,
because in a market like
India, downloading an app
is also a higher commitment.
It requires-- on
an average, a user
would keep five or six
apps on their phone.
And if you want to be
the next job to download,
then that is a high
[? attrition. ?]
There is more friction to that.
What progressive
web apps let us do--
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Five or six apps?
Five or six?
I download five
or six apps a day.
JORDAN: And a lot of the
devices in these markets
have not that much
space on device.
So you're talking about
128 megabytes of memory,
and when you add
in system features,
you have maybe 40
megabytes of user space.
And if a typical APK
is a few megabytes,
you can only have a few of
those before you can really
have to stop downloading.
One of the great things
about progressive web apps
that Anshoo was
mentioning was that you
don't have to request that
commitment right up front.
You can start to build a
relationship with the user
through the web interface.
And over time, the web app
can become more and more
like a native app.
It can be housed on a device.
It can cache content
and work offline.
ANSHOO: In the last
1 and 1/2 weeks
that we have been [? here, ?]
based on these conversations,
we actually launched a micro
version of our platform
on progressive web apps.
On the experience is great.
Without using the app, people
can get as good an experience.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: 1 and 1/2 weeks?
Good work.
JORDAN: I don't deserve
any of the credit.
These guys certainly do.
The only problem is that
none of the merchants
are here in Mountain View.
They're all in India.
So I will never be
able to try it out.
I'll have to stop by sometime.
ANSHOO: We'll find a
way for you to do it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: We
now have Sandeep,
co-founder of Red Carpet.
Sandeep, tell us
about your startup.
SANDEEP: OK, so Red
Carpet basically
lends to customers in India to
fund their online purchases,
whether it be e-commerce
or travel or anything.
Now, in India, credit
and finance companies
barely service 3% of
the customer base.
Because there is
absolutely no data.
There's no credit bureau
data to score and profile
these customers.
Now, Red Carpet
has actually access
to much more data,
which includes
the data on your mobile phone.
Therefore, we are now
able to service customers
who have never had credit
in their life before.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's amazing.
SANDEEP: So India is
basically a country
where 90% of the economy, which
is a trillion dollar economy,
is cash, which
includes e-commerce.
E-commerce is 90% cash.
So banks, even if they look
at your bank statement,
have no data to
process anything.
There's no transactions.
The only transactions that come
up is on your mobile phone.
And that's what we access
to build a profile for you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
And you've been using machine
learning over the last couple
weeks to help out.
SANDEEP: Yes.
So Francisco-- and
we talked a lot
about how we can
leverage machine
learning-- Red Carpet is
fundamentally a data science
company.
We are one of the very few
companies that combine a people
graph, like I'm
connected to you,
with historical
transaction data.
Now, this falls outside the
realm of traditional machine
learning.
And it's not something that
you can just slap package
on and have it work.
So we're a Y Combinator startup.
And when we applied
to Launchpad,
one of the key things
we were looking for
is access to the crown
jewels of Google,
which is like the people who
drive the machine learning.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
This guy right here.
SANDEEP: Now, Francisco
and I talked, I don't know,
for a couple of-- at
least an hour or so.
And we came up with
a new way to combine
graph and traditional
data into a new way
of doing machine learning, which
was pretty freaking awesome
FRANCISCO URIBE: So
Sandeep's example
illustrates really the
flexibility of TensorFlow
programming model.
Historically, we have
seen in the market
that certain tools specialize
in one type of machine learning.
And the idea with
TensorFlow is to provide
a unified computation platform
so that a team can experiment
with models for [? sparse ?]
features, for dense features,
or in the case of Sandeep,
look at more complex things
like graph analysis,
incorporate all of that
to provide more
accurate predictions.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So what's
next for Red Carpet?
SANDEEP: We want to take all
of this learnings back to India
and we're probably going to
build India's largest fintech
company.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's exciting, man.
Thanks for joining us.
SANDEEP: Thank you so much.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Ran, we just talked
to some amazing startups
about their time
at Launchpad Accelerator.
They're using progressive
web apps, machine learning
with TensorFlow, even Firebase.
If there are startups
out there that
want to get involved like
these, where do they go?
RAN NACHMANY: So check
out our link down below.
And we invite you to apply to
the next batch of Launchpad
Accelerator.
We really hope to
see you with us.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
And if you'd like to check
out some of the technologies
that we talked about, we'll
link those below as well.
See you.
RAN NACHMANY: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]